What makes a city? People? Buildings?
Horrific traffic jams? That's not too far off.
It turns out that roads are
what connect all the parts of a city.
We need easy paths to travel from place to place
and for moving materials, supplies, and services.
And in some parts of cities—slums—
that's not happening.
The world's slums lack not only large, easy to travel roads,
but they're also missing a lot of the infrastructure
that goes along with them:
street signs, building numbers, and vehicle access to
building exteriors.
That lack of connectivity means that the billion
people living in slums can't reliably
get their mail, get to work, or even get
to the hospital in an emergency.
Trash removal and sanitation are difficult at best.
Now, scientists are trying to transform slums with
a mathematical approach to urban design called "topology".
Slums can be broken down into two
components:
infrastructure, like homes and stores,
and the access network that links
them.
Nodes and connections.
With this framework, connections --in effect access--
can be optimized.
This new approaches already been used in two slums within Cape Town, South Africa.
In one of the two neighborhoods,
most essential services provided by the city—
water, toilets, electricity, trash removal—
are on the outskirts where road access exists,
but the inner portions of the
settlement—
where temples are—are completely cut off.
In this study scientists used satellite data and
detailed maps handmade by locals to diagram
all the nodes and connections of the settlement.
They then used their topological algorithm to figure out
which areas were inaccessible by roads,
then generated the most cost effective
ways to build roads
and connect them to
outside services.
In topology since one block of buildings
surrounded by roads is considered equivalent,
settlements with a wide range of shapes and sizes,
from the suburbs of Las Vegas to the slums of Mumbai,
can be analyzed in the same way.
The scientists who designed the program
hope to come up with a user-friendly interface that
can be used by communities around the world.
That, they say, would put the decision-making power
into the hands of locals who can determine if proposed
access roads will accommodate their priorities,
then reroute them accordingly.